ميسي ومصيره الغامض مسلسل مستمر
يسخر من فقر برشلونه وما هو شرط اغنى
اغنياء بريطانيا لشراء مانشستر يونايتد
ينضم الى عالم هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها عبر قناه العربيه رياضه اسعدوا
بمتابعتكم
نبدا اخبارنا مع الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
والانباء المتضاربه بشان مستقبله مع ناديه
باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي صحيفه تايمز
خرجت اليوم لتؤكد في تقرير لها ان نادي
العاصمه الفرنسي يرغب في تجديد عقد
البرغوث لموسم اضافي تلك الانباء جاءت
بعدما نشر ميسي مقطع فيديو اعتذر فيه
لاداره
وزملائه عن سفره المفاجئ وبحسب الصحيفه
فان النادي سيعقد جلسه مع خورخي ميسي والد
النجم الارجنتيني خلال الساعات القليله
المقبله من اجل امكانيه التجديد لفتره
اضافيه والله اعلم
والان الى دهاليز قلعه الترا فورد حيث
كشفت تقارير الصحفيه عن وجود شرط في عرض
المليارات الخمس الاسترلينيه الذي قدمه
البريطاني
لشراء مانشستر يونايتد العرض يشترط بيع
الجليزر لجميع ما تبقى لديهم من اسهم
النادي بحلول عام 2006
وبذلك يختفي المالكون الامريكيون عن
المشهد تماما وجاء الكشف عن التفاصيل
الجديده بعد عرض ثالث تقدم به رات كلف
والقطر جاسم بن حمد الثاني
نتحول الى جرى النجم الاسباني المعتزل سخر
من الوضع المالي لناديه السابق برشلونه
بتشبيه طريف انتشر على السوشيال ميديا
سئل خلال مقابله صحفيه عما اذا كان
برشلونه مديرا له
فاجابه بان النادي لا يدين له لا يدين له
حيث تنازل عن مستحقاته كامله وبعد سؤاله
اذا كان يستطيع استعاده مستحقاته الان
اجاب مدافع برشلونه السابق ساخرا يمكن ذلك
ولكن باموالي لعبه المنوبل او ما يعرف
ببنك الحظ وهي لعبه تعتمد على الاوراق
النقديه غير الحقيقيه في اشاره منه الى
الازمه الماليه الخانقه لبرشلونه
الختام مع النجم الامريكيه براد بيت حيث
يستعد لدخول عالم الفورميلا 1 من خلال
فيلمه الجديد
ويتناول هذا الفيلم قصه سائق متقاعد يعود
الى التنافس دعما لنظره المبتدئ ومن
المقرر البدء بتصوير الفيلم تزامنا مع
جائزه بريطانيا الكبرى في التاسع من يوليو
المقبل على حلبه سلفستون وبحسب التقارير
الصحفيه فان ميزانيه الفيلم تصل لاكثر من
140 مليون دولار وسيشارك في انتاجه السائق
لوس هاملتون الذي يلعب دور
المستشار ناريو وتفاصيل الفيلم
[موسيقى]